[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est particulier de venir vous
raconter mon histoire car je suis psy et
coach donc d'habitude j'écoute les gens
mais comme j'ai quelques clés qui
fonctionnent bien pour moi j'ai envie de
les partager avec vous
quand j'étais petit je rêvais d'un monde
magique où tout le monde serait content
gentil et où personne ne freine mal à
personne
enfin j'ai toujours tout fait pour être
la plus gentille possible j'ai été sage
comme une image
j'ai grandi dans une belle maison avec
un jardin un chien un chat mon père
avait des belles voitures ma mère avait
des beaux vêtements nous avons beaucoup
voyagé j'avais des bonnes notes à
l'école
beaucoup de mes amis idéalisé ma famille
de l'extérieur c'était une vie de rêve
de l'extérieur seulement
ce que mes amis ne voyaient pas c'était
les colères de mon père et la souffrance
et la maladie de ma mère
et puis surtout ce que personne ne
voyait c'était la peur et l'état de
vigilance permanent dans lequel je me
trouve
mon père se mettait hors de lui il
menaçait parfois de tuer ma mère
je vivais dans une peur constante de la
mort et pour cause il m'a cogné la tête
contre un mur quand j'étais bébé
alors on me l'a raconté je m'en souviens
pas
mais mon corps en a gardé des traces
et c'est peut-être même pour ça que je
suis devenu psy
donc parfois tout allait bien à la
maison et parfois c'était la crise
c'était imprévisible comme tous les
enfants je pensais que ce que je vivais
était normal que toutes les familles
étaient comme la mienne avec un mélange
d'amour et de violence
des toutes petites j'ai donc appris à
faire le moins de vagues possible pour
ne pas déclencher de tempête
j'aurais tellement aimé que tout soit
magique
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas
ma mère était bipolaire et suicidaire
elle a tenté de me tuer avec elle à deux
reprises
la première fois j'avais 7 ans elle m'a
tendu une trentaine de somnifères en
proposant que nous les prenions ensemble
j'ai dit non
pourtant j'étais toute petite mais j'ai
senti
que c'était pas normal
moi je voulais vivre
la seconde fois elle a eu un accès de
folie sur le toroute elle a lâché le
volant et nous avons percuté un camion
et le rail de sécurité
j'avais 10 ans j'ai cru que c'était la
fin j'ai pas eu le temps de réagir je me
suis dit qu'elle avait réussi son coup
miraculeusement nous sommes toutes les
deux sorties vivantes de l'accident la
preuve je suis là
ma mère était internée régulièrement en
hôpital psychiatrique
et comme mon père
quand ma mère n'était pas là mon père
m'a fait subir des attouchements
ça aussi ça laisse des traces indélébile
bon ça fait beaucoup pour une seule
petite fille
mais ça fait beaucoup pour n'importe
quel enfant maltraité
puis mon histoire elle ressemble
malheureusement à celle de beaucoup trop
d'enfants
en France un enfant sur cinq est victime
de violences sexuelles
et un enfant meurt tous les cinq jours
des coups de ses parents
malgré ses événements difficiles j'ai
toujours cru que j'avais une bonne
étoile c'est sans doute pour ça que tout
au long de ma vie j'ai rencontré ce que
j'appelle des bonnes fées et là je suis
certaine que vous en avez tous rencontré
vous aussi elles n'ont pas du tout de
baguettes magiques et de petites ailes
pas du tout non non c'est simplement un
homme ou une femme qui avec la bonne
phrase au bon moment vous permet de
dépasser votre peur de rendre possible
quelque chose d'impossible
à 16 ans la mère d'une amie éducatrice
pour enfants m'a parlé de la maladie de
ma mère la bipolarité
c'est grâce à elle que j'ai compris que
je n'étais pas responsable que les
médecins s'occupaient de ma mère et
surtout que je ne pourrais jamais la
sauver
cette discussion m'a sauvé moi
c'est ça que j'appelle une bonne fée
l'année de mon bac je me suis donc
débrouillée pour déménager à Paris et
faire une école de théâtre
mes parents se sont séparés peu de temps
après mon départ mais comme j'ai voyais
moins j'avais l'impression de moins
souffrir
sauf que petit à petit j'ai réalisé que
mon ventre se tordait de douleur
plusieurs jours avant d'aller les voir
encore me disait stop mais je ne
l'écoutais pas
ma mère ressemblait de plus en plus à un
fantôme à cause de sa maladie et mon
père lors d'un dîner en tête à tête m'a
dit que c'est moi qui leur ai dit
épouser
je sais
comme il était sérieux en le disant
c'était glaçant et puis voilà là je me
dis ok c'est la goutte d'eau ça va et là
une deuxième bonne est intervenue
toujours pas de baguette elle était
simplement psy c'est déjà pas mal
et c'est elle qui m'a appris que
maintenant que j'étais adulte j'étais
pas obligé de voir mes parents non non
on a le droit de faire ça autrement si
ça me faisait souffrir je pouvais
choisir autre chose
alors bien sûr comme tous les enfants
j'ai même mes parents malgré tout ce qui
m'avait fait
mais j'ai compris que les voir ça me
faisait vraiment trop de mal alors il
m'a fallu du courage
mais j'ai compris que je pouvais pas
continuer à me sacrifier si je vous
laisse survivre
donc j'ai cessé de les voir
en prenant cette décision de me libérer
de mes parents la vie m'a apporté plein
de choses nouvelles
j'ai rencontré un homme charmant nous
nous sommes mariés nous avons eu deux
filles magnifiques ma carrière de
comédienne s'est très bien développée
j'étais épanouie et heureuse là je me
suis dit c'est bon j'ai eu une enfance
difficile ok très bien je me suis j'ai
souffert ça va maintenant ça va aller
bon la vie n'est décidément pas un conte
de fée et souvent quand on a été
traumatisme dans l'enfance
les schémas se répètent
une nouvelle épreuve c'est présenté à
moi et dans ma vie professionnelle cette
fois-ci alors tout en continuant ma
carrière de comédienne j'ai envie de
diversifier mes activités moi j'avais
besoin d'apprendre pendant 10 ans j'ai
repris des études je suis devenue
formatrice puis
coach certifié
psychopraticienne j'ai même passé un
diplôme universitaire à la Sorbonne vous
savez sur quoi on devine
l'adolescence difficile oui un peu
obligé
et donc grâce à ses études j'ai commencé
à travailler pour une entreprise en tant
que formatrice je me sens je me sentais
chanceux j'avais l'impression d'avoir
trouvé une nouvelle famille
professionnelle les dirigeants
valorisaient beaucoup et je m'entendais
bien avec eux
sauf que progressivement la valorisation
s'est transformée en dénigrement
je travaillais beaucoup pour eux et je
me sentais de plus en plus mal à nouveau
j'avais mal au ventre
mais je continuais parce qu'ils avaient
été très gentils au début alors j'espère
que ça redevienne comme avant et puis
aussi je pensais que j'avais une place
particulière pourtant j'étais même pas
salarié j'étais indépendante j'avais cet
espoir comme ça
et
ils étaient dans leur mode habituel
c'est-à-dire que c'est un mode que vous
avez fait avec d'autres qu'avec moi
c'était séduction emprise maltraitance
et ça je connais bien donc moi fidèle à
moi-même j'étais
dans ma quête de reconnaissance je me
soumettais et je me sacrifiais
cette fois là c'est mon corps qui a
réagit et de façon extrêmement violente
c'était sans doute l'accumulation des
violences que j'avais vécu jusqu'ici
le diagnostic est tombé cancer du sein 9
mois de traitement lourd
ça peut paraître surprenant mais ce
cancer m'a fait moins peur que la
réaction de mes employeurs
j'avais tellement peur qu'il me supprime
toutes mes missions que j'ai décidé de
ne rien leur dire j'avais trop peur de
me retrouver sans revenu en plus d'être
malade
pendant plusieurs mois c'était chimio le
lundi boulot le reste de la semaine
je n'ai pas raté un seul jour de travail
je voulais respecter mes engagements
comme quand j'étais petite je ne voulais
pas faire de vagues pour ne pas créer de
tempête
alors bien sûr il y a eu l'équipe
médicale mon mari mes amis mes filles
toute cette armée de bonnes fées m'ont
soutenu pendant toute cette période là
la rémission du cancer a été totale
à la fin des traitements je me suis dit
je vais annoncer à mes employeurs les
profs que je viens de traverser je
pensais qu'ils allaient enfin être
reconnaissants de mon engagement
indéfectible pour eux par un jour de
travail manquait quand même
vous savez ce qui m'ont répondu
comment as-tu pu nous faire ça
comment as-tu pu nous faire ça le temps
que ça monte à mon cerveau waouh ils
m'ont même pas demandé comment j'allais
je n'ai plus jamais revu ses employeurs
c'est là que j'ai vraiment compris que
personne n'a le droit de traiter
quiconque de cette façon nous sommes
faits pour recevoir de la considération
de la gentillesse mais pas pour être
maltraité
donc à partir de ce moment je me suis
juré d'écouter mon corps de le
considérer comme ma boussole
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait il
m'avait toujours indiqué ce qui était
bon ou mauvais pour moi
j'ai donc décidé grande résolution de ne
plus jamais travailler avec des
personnes
maltraitantes ou abusives
j'étais fier bon vous savez ce qui s'est
passé non c'est ça c'est ça qui est
drôle c'est que en fait la vie nous
ramène toujours nous teste en fait ça et
ça y est quoi et donc il y a une
nouvelle entreprise que j'ai rencontré
et là ils m'ont proposé de me de me
dédier entièrement à dire de cesser
toutes mes autres activités alors j'ai
j'allais avoir plein d'argent plein de
promesses et merveilleux et mon corps
c'est
j'ai senti que ça n'allait pas du tout
mais cette fois-ci je l'ai écouté
j'ai vu le schéma de répétition j'ai dit
non
c'est à partir de là que ma vie c'est
vraiment transformé
dans tous les domaines je me suis mise à
rencontrer les bonnes personnes des gens
gentils et bienveillants
et puis le bon attire le bon donc je
suis entré dans un cercle vertueux
c'était incroyable
j'ai eu j'adore écrire j'ai eu envie de
mener une enquête autour du cancer du
sein et de la santé psychologique il y a
300 femmes qu'on répondu je savais pas
du tout comment diffuser mon article
j'étais très voilà et en fait une bonne
amie m'a mise en relation avec un grand
magazine hebdomadaire ils ont accepté de
me publier
ensuite une collepsie c'est jante à moi
et on a mené deux autres études qui ont
été reprises par de nombreux magazines
pouf je suis devenu journaliste
ensuite j'ai un bon ami qui m'a mis en
relation avec une entreprise
partagez les mêmes valeurs et dès notre
première rencontre ils m'ont confié
trois projets passionnants
ça fait des années que je travaille avec
j'ai toujours autant de plaisir un jour
il y a un des responsables qui m'a dit
tu es l'âme du projet
ouais je sais c'est
et puis aussi bah oui je comme je suis
aussi comédienne j'ai décroché en fait
je fais partie des voies permanentes
d'une grande radio nationale
et puis c'est des comédiens qu'on
donnait mes coordonnées et après
plusieurs mois j'ai appris qu'ils
avaient dit que j'étais une vraie
gentille qu'avec moi tout se passerait
bien
et que j'ai un grand cœur
donc c'était mouf
pour moi
aujourd'hui
dans ma vie personnelle avec ma petite
famille
nous ne vivons pas dans une grande
maison mais dans un appartement
nous avons un chien une voiture
nos filles ont de très très bonnes notes
à l'école mais ça c'est pour l'extérieur
à l'intérieur le plus important c'est
que nous vivons dans la joie
et nous nous amusons beaucoup
ma décision est la bonne je choisis mon
entourage
ça n'a pas toujours été facile
mais c'est un choix
je choisis de ne fréquenter que des gens
que j'apprécie dans ma vie personnelle
et professionnelle
les autres je les laisse simplement
vivre leur vie sans moi
cette question du choix des gens qui
vous entourent et fondamental
nous n'avons qu'une seule vie qu'un seul
corps
donc il y a pas de temps à perdre avec
les gens maltraitants irrespectueux
abusif nous ne sommes pas condamnés à
vivre avec des gens qui nous font
souffrir nous ne sommes pas condamnés à
répéter notre traumatisme
vous l'avez compris il y a pas de magie
finalement
c'est à chacun d'entre nous de créer la
vie que nous avons envie de vivre
et pour cela mes petits trucs à moi
maintenant c'est il m'aura fallu du
temps
mais c'est simplement d'écouter cette
petite voix intérieure d'écouter mon
cœur et d'écouter les mots du corps
quand le corps parle c'est important
c'est comme ça qu'on peut se
tranquilliser se sécuriser à l'intérieur
attention il y a un effet
convaincue que nous pouvons tous
choisir
de nous entourer des bonnes personnes
pour nous pour faire et vivre de belles
choses merci pour votre écoute